s'est il passé pour que ma cause est fbi
beau réussissent à se rendre jusqu'au
parlement
alors que la grc devait assurer la
sécurité sur les terrains de la colline
ce sont des lacunes systémiques et non
une erreur humaine qui ont permis aux
tirs ardente et dans l'édifice du centre
il s'est écoulé une minute 47 secondes
entre le moment osé avis bo a quitté le
monument commémoratif de guerre et celui
où il a franchi les portes du parlement
quand le forcené s'est emparé de la
limousine d'un ministre une policière
déjà alerté par une passante a tenté de
prévenir ses collègues par radio la
communication s'est avéré
incompréhensible trois policiers qui se
trouvaient dans des autopatrouilles eux
n'ont rien vu
ça n'est pas des employés qui sont à
blâmer j'aime la peine à imposer
l'hypothèse que si l'individu à na li
s'est pas embarqué dans le véhicule en
question du déni tu fais un bon nombre
des failles qui ont été identifiés ont
été censurés tout comme les 66
recommandations le rapport soulève que
le dispositif de sécurité de la grc
présente de nombreuses difficultés en
raison des ressources limitées qui y
sont affectés
une conséquence des coupes budgétaires
de 2012
la réponse du ministre des finances non
non ce poste
c'est vraiment préoccupant il faut
regarder ça vraiment de fond en comble
depuis ils attaquent les trois
différentes forces de sécurité au
parlement celle de la grc de la chambre
des communes et du sénat ont entrepris
un processus d'intégration et la plupart
des gardiens à l'intérieur du parlement
sont maintenant armés environ
peut-être les toits ou encore de la
commande à sion qui ont été appliquées
ou sont sur le point d'attaquer la
balance des recommandations c'est des
recommandations qui parle d'
investissement majeur qui nécessite plus
d'analytics ces mois après l'attaqué
beaucoup reste à faire marc quand on
constate toutes ces failles on se dit
qu'on a évité le pire mais de justesse
céline je vous rappelle qu'il y avait
énormément de monde ce matin là au
parlement et s'il attaque n'a pas été
plus meurtrières c'est dans le fond
michael zehaf bibeau était très peu
organisé son acte sommairement planifier
la grc qui tire donc des leçons de sa
réaction plutôt lente et désordonnée
pourtant il y avait déjà eu des signaux
d'alarmé
en 2009 par exemple il ya une vingtaine
de militants greenpeace qui avait réussi
à déjouer la grc en déployant une
bannière sur l'édifice de l'ouest en
2012 par la suite le vérificateur
général révéler justement dans un
rapport des lacunes sur le plan de la
sécurité
alors la grc se retrouve aujourd'hui sur
la défensive
l'ironie est qu'elle se fait taper sur
les doigts céline alors qu'on vient de
lui confier le commandement des forces
de sécurité à l'extérieur et à
l'intérieur du parlement
merci de ces précisions marque revoir